welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and Rick and Morty season four
released an official trailer for the
first half of its season coming November
10th with presumably the second five
episodes coming early 2020 and we are
back diving into this delightfully
universe of universes for all the hidden
animation details references callbacks
all the jokes who bring you in on the
inside jokes and feel like less of a I'm
gonna break down this trailer shot by
shot to get a sense of what episodes we
might be looking at what subtle jokes
they're already sneaking in there in
what insane theories we might have just
gotten confirmed spoiler warning again
soon my speculation is too accurate
never ruins you're alive let's get
started
okay the trailer opens on Rick's ship
swooping into this picturesque planet
the same one from the animation still
that was released last summer if you
look closely he appears to be alone in
the ship meaning this is likely a
different moment than the next shot that
shows Rick and Morty entering this
Raiders of the Lost Ark style temple
notice these spike traps on the ceiling
the circular patterns on the floor
probably where more spikes will shoot up
as they walk over them just like they
did on Indy later they'll zip on these
protective suits to block the darts it
should have the walls wondering what
those statues are maybe it's the
statutes backpack so the part of me is
wondering if whether these could be like
ancient Morty statues maybe some ancient
cult of interdimensional Morty's from an
older time oh and by the way the music
throughout this trailer is the idiom
beats of Justice the tracks of Genesis
and stress next Morty runs with chachi a
blue cat creature away from these tongue
slug looking cards in their brains
something back at his backpack for Rick
and then shot his head blown open I like
how the animators tangled his tongue out
they also frame Rick through chat shades
wound hole they've done a similar shot
before like when Rick lasered the guards
and the head and they pick a Rick
episode moving on to this shot of
Morty's scaling up a cliff wall wall
Rick floats beside them in a hover chair
isn't a maje to the scene in Star Trek 5
the final frontier the best of the Star
Trek movies it's not when Kirk climbs El
Capitan in Yosemite and Spock floats up
next to him in hover boots just like
Morty does Kirk Falls Spock swoops down
to save them we'll see if Rick's is nice
actually if you look closely you can see
the reason Morty loses his grip is a
little critter that crawls
out and pokes bytes hint when Rick's
fast food bag floats by you can see that
it is an Arby's bag adding Arby's to
Carl's jr. and McDonald's as Rick and
Morty fast food chain cross promotions
let us see how many fans lose their
minds trying to get a limited-edition
Rick roast beef or whatever it is then
Rick and Morty tried to mine these blue
crystals out of a geode before ending up
in a shootout and then Rick and summer
are nearly incinerated by dragon fire
that's the end of the morning it's a
dragon experiment are you gonna say it
first off I always slay it Queen
secondly yes
hey Rick sounds like he is family in his
inner RuPaul there and assuming Morty
does have a dragon I'm wondering if one
of the episodes could be a D&D episode
that deals with magic as a scientist
rick has always been skeptical of magic
as we saw in the something Rick it this
way comes episode in season one but
later this trailer Rick summer Morty do
appear to be in a kind of D&D style cave
scenario summer looks like she's dressed
up as some kind of deity character Rick
finally embraces magic now if you look
around this dungeon you could see a
skeleton of some creature caged up above
them wondering this could be a dragon
skeleton like the ones in the red keep
even Thrones given Rick and Morty's past
role in the Game of Thrones post final
season of Game of Thrones could be a
wonderful time to get some more jokes in
Rick uses this magic device to turn an
enemy into a football which he punts and
then the next enemy into a flower vase
now this could be a nod to the
Hitchhiker's Guide in the galaxy one of
the many influences on Rick and Morty's
sci-fi absurdism there's a moment in
which the missiles are randomly
transformed into a sperm whale in a bowl
of petunias curiously the only thing
that went through the mind of the bowl
of petunias as it fell was oh no not
again moving on through the trailer we
also get the return of mr. meeseeks is
looking delighted as they riot and
destroy his city street presumably their
task is a more long-term one like
destabilizing society which is why they
aren't screaming existence is pain right
now since their amazing introduction in
the season 1 episode meeseeks and
destroy' a few mr. meeseeks have popped
up here and they're like in season 2 the
background of blips and shits in in
season 3 in a cage in one of the Morty's
mind-blower memories then there's this
wild shot of beth and summer melee
fighting on an airport tarmac Beth with
a broom and a trash can lid summer with
a golf club presumably taken from the
clubs on a luggage rack back there
there's a huge hole
the glass on the walkway above who knows
what the hell's going on here but next
up there's a shot of morty taking down
some bullies with bats there's one stuck
in some goo another sucked into an orb
like device actually the second bully
might look familiar to you he was one of
the [ __ ] that summer and Rick beat
up and ex gonna give it to you montage
and when people thought looks like
Randall from recess the cop pulls up and
radios in he's representing Akira in
which the government experimented on
kids to create super soldiers but then
one of them Tetsuo becomes too powerful
it's like more to hear and if you look
closely at Morty he has some glowing
devices on the side of his head now some
are saying this could make him evil
Morty but as we saw in season three evil
Morty is now president of the Citadel
I'd imagine he'd have some bigger plans
in his mind then like bully revenge so
perhaps this Morty is being like
remotely controlled or maybe just not
fully in control of his own actions as
he has been weaponized the next there's
a shot of this monsters head being
melted but acid kind of looks like
mutant cherry to me but whatever this is
it has like this kind of fungal growth
in a second mouth in the second set of
teeth inside its main mouth it's all
appearance in the noise it makes as it
melts evokes the alien from John
Carpenter's The Thing
this could be connected to that cloning
microwave that Rick has in the garage in
which human flesh comes out looking kind
of raw and primordial like this and then
Rick gives Morty this Sal for 10 minutes
or you'll die
don't let it sit for 12 or I'll have to
hunt down what you become in the
episodes final clip we see exactly what
Rick will have to hunt down as Morty
morphs into this demonic beef what did I
tell you I'm thinking this all could
have started with what Morty was
suffering from in that other clip no I'm
just usually around people that die
faster notice that snake in the
astronaut style spacesuit with a broken
helmet this space snake must have bitten
Morty and poisoned his bloodstream maybe
leading to him turning into this demon
okay moving on in the trailer there's a
shot of Jerry and Morty crashing into a
room with a bunch of red armored
soldiers based on Jerry's stupid track
suit this is most likely the episode
would take a with TZ voice in glooty
from that clip shown at Comic Con Hootie
helps jerry develop a dating app called
love finders to ours because jerry and
that clip morty tries to shut down the
app and the glooty hints that the server
is on a mothership which is coming so
presumably this is the mothership and
these soldiers whose feet look just like
Rudy's feet are using Jerry's app maybe
as a homing beacon to come attack the
sad single people of Earth or something
next there's a shot of Rick and Morty
entering a kind of fan convention hall
there's a few familiar background
characters present including mark hate
alien for the morning night run episode
a few others from blips and shits are at
this convention as well there's also a
three boob a lien like Jerry's
girlfriend Kiara last season both a nod
to the three boob woman of Total Recall
Rick fade shifts through a security
guard by touching the inside of his lab
coat which then uses in another great
move Rick is referring to dr. Strange's
cloak of levitation footman irony since
Dan Harmon consulted on the script for
the Doctor Strange film you know they
didn't use all of his ideas Rick as a
character seems weirdly aware of other
dimension hopping doctors of pop culture
you don't know what I could do later in
the trailer Rick and Morty will zip up
from this convention hall to a ship on
the roof as they blast off you can see
that this is a heist convention thus why
fans can be seen on the roof tearing up
pieces of it and pasting them I guess
Morty's wearing this red backpack here
so this heist could be part of that same
episode where chachi dies maybe this all
be Justin roiland and Dan Harmon's
commentary on fan convention culture
something they know very well before I
continue big thanks to Mack Weldon for
sponsoring this breakdown Mack Weldon
makes great clothing with smart design
and premium fabrics while making the
shopping process real simple like I
picked up this silver knit polo and it
was super easy to find the right size
and just place the order and you know
what shirts plus the cozy underwear that
I'm not gonna show you that's lost after
dark exclusive but all their stuff their
socks shirts under shirts hoodies
sweatpants it is all super cool it
doesn't have the cloak of levitation
powers that Rick's lab coat does but it
does trick the eye into giving me
shoulders so it is in a way magic these
clothes are great for wearing at work
like this shirt is but also they got
stuff for everyday life and for working
out for going on dates with your partner
who definitely exists in if not well
soon because you look great in your new
Mac Weldon shirts and Mac Weldon is
giving you guys 20% off your first order
all you got to do is visit Mac Weldon
calm and enter the promo code
new rock stars that's one word or click
on the link in the description and again
that's promo code new rock stars ok back
to the trailer mr. poopy butthole
returns perhaps now professor poopy
butthole in a college lecture hall now
whatever he's lecturing about is really
setting off these hips or students who
ninja down to him an attack he uses his
cane kind of like Galahad with
umbrella in the Kingsmen actually if you
go frame-by-frame you can see each of
these dudes spewing out blood when mr.
CooCoo butthole takes him down my guess
is that this episode could feature mr.
poopy butthole as a professor who says
something offensive during a lecture and
it gets attacked by all the triggered
students maybe even the rioting mr.
meeseeks are an extension of the rage of
these students then Rick fights a rock
monster which could be set and that may
be D&D episode I mentioned earlier the
fact that rick has morphine in a spinal
cord yet another component of a
cybernetic skeleton that we have seen
glimpses of before this Mike Lewis end
tube how rick has been able to withstand
so much pain next up an insane shot of
Rick piloting his ship with Nazi Morty
fighting enemies seeks triggering a
German Luger pistol to kill also
recurring minor character gearhead
yeah I couldn't even begin to speculate
on what is going on here my guess is
that this could be one of the random
nonsensical clips that play in the new
opening credits and then finally there
is what I consider to be the oddest
moment of the trailer you know what this
one counts as one of your adventures
okay here's what's weird about it
this Morty adventure card is a callback
to the season three indicators episode
hi Morty Smith invoke my right to choose
one in every 10 Rick and Morty
adventures wait a minute
damn it fine but don't say I didn't warn
you that card already got its 10th stamp
now I would say Rick could have given
Morty a new card and then they've
already gotten through that second one
but the orientation of each of the
stamps is exactly the same in fact this
is the same exact animation cell as that
season 3 episode with Rick's helmet
device off to the right - these slugs
that they were trying to catch in that
scene this could be evidence of the
popular theory that many of the Rick and
Morty episodes are actually showing us
different Rick's and Morty's from
throughout the infinite multiverse some
have pointed out that at least once
which occurred during the Morty night
run episode when Jerry left the day care
center with a different Rick and Morty
than the ones he and we arrived with and
then in the following episode total Rick
Hall the green rocks that Rick scavenged
in the morning night run episode are
seen when Rick throws them away in the
garbage with those pink crystals being
revealed as a source of the memory virus
that plagues the family in that episode
suggesting that everything from then on
in the series is at least one new Rick
and Morty but in general the idea
is that every episode represents chaos
and the multiverse of Rick and Morty is
the writers met a commentary on episodic
television so returning to the stamp
could be the same kind of thing perhaps
we'll see a Rick and Morty in a
different dimension go on a slightly
different Morty toes an adventure in
that Vindicator z' experience if you
remember one of the pieces of concept
art for the season showed Rick with the
people of the Vindicator Crocky BOTS
perhaps that could be connected with
this slightly alternate adventure what
are you most looking forward to about
Rick and Morty's season for comment down
below with your thoughts
now with Rick and Morty returning I am
hoping to resume our weekly breakdowns
of all the in animation details in each
episode also big announcement here we
have gotten a blessing from Dan Harmon
himself to do an official Rick and Morty
after-show to discuss each episodes
deeper agenda with special guests but in
case you hadn't heard we are temporarily
sort of homeless here two rock stars and
we are rushing to finish construction
for our new project new rock stars
Digital Studios so it's just gonna be
tough to keep up with all this Rick and
Morty content that we are eager to bring
you guys so to help us expedite this by
the time season 4 premieres it would
really really help us if you could
become a patron of n RDS for your
generosity you don't get access to bonus
content including a monthly exclusive
premium breakdown that I guess I'm gonna
have to find time to do and you'll help
us create this place where we can nerd
out on Rick and Morty together every
week so if you are able to help us out
with that please click on the link in
the description below follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA vas thank
you for joining me and for any Rick and
Morty fans out there who insist on hate
watching every youtube video about it
and snarking in the comments that the
host isn't the right kind of fan like
you are much obliged
[Music]